estas imágenes se han convertido en un
símbolo de la brutalidad de la guerra en
ucrania un hospital maternal de mariupol
bombardeado por las fuerzas rusas el 9
de marzo
estábamos tumbados en las habitaciones
con las puertas las ventanas y los muros
han estallado en mil pedazos
la mayoría de las madres aturdidas
agotadas y heridas han podido dar a luz
por cesárea a bebés en buen estado de
salud
[Música]
pero otras no tuvieron esta suerte una
menor ingresada en el ala pediátrica del
hospital murió en el ataque y esta mujer
filmada durante la evacuación acabó
falleciendo igual que el hijo que estaba
hemos practicado una cesárea y sacados
un niño sin vida más de 30 minutos de
reanimación de la madre y el hijo no han
dado resultado
según las autoridades ucranianas al
menos 90 menores murieron desde el
inicio de la guerra y gran parte de los
que sobrevivieron huyen del país con sus
familias una travesía en condiciones
precarias en países que no conocen un
millón de menores han llegado a la unión
europea tenemos que centrarnos en ellos
para darles una vida un poco normal en
el exilio e incluso en los países donde
encuentran asilo y regresan a la escuela
permanece el traumatismo de la guerra
los menores han perdido su estabilidad y
han asistido a escenas impactantes que
no saben cómo contextualizar la
situación se agrava para los niños
enfermos a los que la guerra ha
interrumpido los tratamientos aunque
decenas de ellos han sido admitidos en
hospitales europeos